[Applause]
[Music]
Thursday December 28th 2017 the year is
bound to end and the world gets ready to
welcome 2018 like every year news rooms
are practically on pause and only talk
about three basic topics reuse on 2017
predictions of what 2018 may bring and
news about how the arrival of the new
year will be celebrated in nearly every
corner of the world
[Music]
however if you are on Thursday December
28th when the year seemed to be over
this news came out numerous protests and
demonstrations began to emerge
throughout Iran it all began in the city
of Machado historic Shiite pilgrimage
site the hometown of the supreme leader
Ayatollah Khamenei and one of the
bastions of the regime while
surprisingly it was here in this Islamic
Revolution sanctuary that the first
anti-government protests emerged some
demonstrations spread quickly throughout
the country resulting in more than 20
deaths and over a thousand detainees at
that time when everything was beginning
many people wondered if we were
witnessing the birth of a new kind of
Persian Spring the President of the
United States Donald Trump seemed to
suggest that Iran is failing at every
level despite the terrible deal made
with them by the Obama administration
the great Iranian people have been
repressed for many years they are hungry
for food and for freedom along with
human rights the wealth of Iran is being
looted time for change but just the
moments if we really witnessed an
incipient Persian spring have we really
seen the powerful Ayatollah regime
wobble well no we haven't not imminently
at least you'll see what I mean in just
a moment
[Music]
however not being at the beginning of a
Persian spring doesn't mean that Iran
isn't undergoing events that are very
important to the country's future and by
extension important to the future of the
Middle East so to viewer here we have
three key questions first why do these
protests occur what were their cause
seconds who lit this entire movement
spark and third what can we expect will
these events have any effect on Iran
well let's answer these three questions
and see why all of these movements show
us how the Islamic Revolution in Iran
the totalitarian regime that now
controls the country is facing rapid
erosion
[Music]
the fires causes
as we've seen in previous videos here on
visual politic Iran is one of the
countries with the most natural
resources in the world it has the fourth
largest oil reserves the second largest
natural gas reserves and their copper
iron zinc uranium and silver deposits
among many other resources are also
among the largest in the world and
that's not all if that weren't enough it
also has a relatively young and
well-educated population for example
every year almost 5 million young people
attend University in principle it seems
like this country should have an easy
time getting things to go well for it
however despite this its economy is a
disaster there's a pressing employment
shortage in Iran especially for the
youngest who suffer unemployment rates
of 40% inflation is also in the double
digits the currency has suffered notable
depreciation and the government has been
forced to cut several social benefits
and this all clashes head-on with the
huge expectations generated from the
2015 nuclear agreements see there was
widespread hope that this government
would be a turning point for the
country's economy investments would
begin to arrive and world markets would
reopen to do business with Iran
president rouhani himself supported this
thesis and the truth is since the
agreement was signed thinks they have
improved since many of the sanctions
were lifted in 2016 not all of them
though the United States actually still
maintains several oil production has
increased by 20% public accounts have
improved and the growth rate has sought
to almost 7 percent
[Music]
however these changes haven't been
enough among other things because the
Iranian economy has more holes than
Swiss cheese see corruption is very
widespread the good section of the
economy is in the hands of corporations
that are linked to politicians religious
foundations and the powerful
Revolutionary Guard and they of course
receive all kinds of privileges it isn't
fair that a lot of Iranians suffer while
a large part of the budget is allocated
to Islamic organizations whose functions
we don't know that well poverty takes
over everything even people's religion
Musa a retired person and participate in
the protest rallies in Tehran in fact it
is estimated that a bit more than 20
percent of the economy belongs to what
we might consider the purely private
sector yep really only 20 percent see
doing business in Iran is really really
complicated see the World Bank's Doing
Business ranking which measures how easy
it is to do business in a country ranked
Iran in position 124 and if we take a
look at their economic Freedom Index the
results are even worse they occupy the
one hundred and fifty fifth place and
well Iran it isn't even a World Trade
Organization member and it maintains
average tariffs of approximately twenty
five percent
[Music]
and if that weren't enough the
government spends huge resources abroad
in Syria Lebanon Iraq and Yemen for
example which in addition to spending a
lot of Iran's scarce money fuels the
investment community's panic just think
about it for a moment who is willing to
invest their savings in a country like
Iran
I mean don't tell me that's not just a
little bit scary the main problem comes
from the revolutions export ideology and
from supporting the Shiite groups from
Lebanon to Yemen the system spends money
on these campaigns without taking the
needs of the people into account Farah
Mars law student and activist of course
the result of this disastrous model
falls on the shoulders of Iran's
citizens especially its youngest and
this is important here because it is
estimated that around 50% of the
country's population is less than 30
years old now we know what sparked this
protest but who is behind all of this
who organized the first rallies could it
actually have been the United States as
the Tehran regime denounced could it
have been a well-organized and
well-prepared political opposition well
let's see and listen of it because you
might be surprised
the instigator
[Music]
at first there were as usual several
interpretations about what was happening
and one of them was the theory that a
popular revolution could be starting a
very particular Persian spring however
the viewer it was soon clear that some
pieces did not seem to fit at all see on
the one hand protests exploded in some
of the most controlled and most
talkative cities in the country on the
other hands unlike for example the
so-called 2009 Green Revolution this
time the main role did not fall on the
middle classes which tend to be more
secular and reformist but curiously on
the poorer conservative passes and on
top of that the first protester messages
were aimed mainly at the president's
brain isn't clear who has organized
these demonstrations but most slogans
were against rouhani Hama parties
Meszaros editor-in-chief see even though
elections are held in Iran to choose the
president candidates are ultimately
chosen by the supreme leader the
Ayatollah who at the moment of truth has
the last word this is why he's the
supreme leader while the fact is that
President rouhani is that's a reformist
and a soft-hearted political leader of
course there's much of a reformist and
soft-hearted political leader as we
could expect in a regime like Iran's and
while he may not have reached every
expectation he did take some steps
towards a certain amount of openness in
the country under mr. rouhani strict
Islamic rules have been somewhat relaxed
concerts have been allowed and the
morals police are largely off the
streets illegal parties are usually no
longer rated although there have been
exceptions so if what you're demanding
are more reforms and more freedom
attacking the most reformist president
would seem at the very least rather
curious don't you think well as you
might imagine this does have an
explanation
the powerful Revolutionary Guards main
chief himself Muhammad Ali Jafari made
it very clear at first the instigators
leader was none other than the former
President Ahmadinejad himself
that's right ultra conservative groups
organized the first protests to erode
the reformists political capital bird of
course in a country where 50% of the
population is less than 30 where there
is widespread frustration and above all
smartphones and Internet access
it's not a surprise that the contagion
spread very quickly within hours the
calls to protest spread through social
networks and communication applications
such as telegram the most popular
application in the country suddenly
spontaneous protests broke out all over
the country
and of course complaints about the
economic situation were soon joined by
demands for freedom yes we could really
say that all of this got rather out of
hands for the ultra conservatives
of course the government didn't take
long to reactants use the force we can
all imagine a dictatorship like this has
detentions considerable threats and even
capital punishment due to rebellion
treason connection with foreign
intelligence services all began as for
the recent days developments in the
country enemies have been united to
create problems for the Islamic system
by using various means including money
weapons politics and security apparatus
Ayatollah Khomeini the response was so
big that the government has just
announced a prohibition on teaching
English in primary schools supposedly to
avoid cultural invasion as you can
imagine all of this stops the protests
however even though we aren't facing a
Persian spring the fact is that all
these events showed several of the
totalitarian regimes weaknesses
[Music]
the weakness of a failed revolution
since the Islamic Revolution took place
back in 1979 the Tehran government has
made a lot of effort to achieve a strong
national identity built on religion see
according to the Iranian news agency
there are more than one and a half
million yes one and a half million
clerics teaching the Quran and promoting
Islamic principles in schools and in all
kinds of educational institutions
[Music]
however despite all these efforts
Iranian society which as we saw is very
very young is becoming increasingly
secular and increasingly dissatisfied
with a country model that lies far from
their way of thinking as you can imagine
the Internet has played a key role in
all of this well if we add the regime's
inability to generate opportunities for
all these young people - all of this it
isn't unreasonable to think that we will
witness a very fast erosion of this
country's political pillars in the next
few yes mind you this is harder to
imagine in Saudi Arabia and even then we
are beginning to see it with the changes
that Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman is
introducing while Iranian society is
much more open much more secular
independent of religion and better
formed so well we'll just have to wait
and see for now it's your turn do you
think that the Ayatollah regime will be
able to contain such a changing force
will we begin to see changes in Iran
well leave your answer in the comments
below as well as in this survey and I
really hope you enjoyed this video if
you did please do hit that like button
below and don't forget we put up brand
new videos every Monday and every
Thursday and please do check out our
friends at the reconsider Media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]